ブーバー6は良いこれがホワイトでこれが dodo
今俺はなこっちでこの闇の力と聖なる2日の使い分けで留学してるんですけど
フルブラックのサーフィンはね闇の力が宿ってとまらだけなんですよかけの葉
本当に危ないですねこれはいい
でこっちの白いのがねちょっと思う
真っ白なんだよ
ね履けばの王様なんですよ在勤はちょっとこのすごいの
使ってこんなに
こう正義としてねやっぱねーよねさばいていきたいと思ってるんですけどこんな中二
病的な話はいいんですよ
この動画見てる人の中でも
いてほしいんですけどいっしょ角で分防護柵
皆さんペン好きでしょ高校時代50本以上わかってるんで
僕だねちょっと僕のじゃねえはもうお前のに今日はサーフィンの良さを知ると思います
できました4つ準備はいいか飾るぞ
まずは特待でリップか話していこうと思いますかっこいいよねもうみんな自然と思い
ました時たいといってまぁここからドクターグリップは略称とくぐりと呼ばせて
いただきますまずは所内の毒栗ですこれは僕が小学校とにた飛ばされるドクター
グリップのにまたじゃない人が多いかもしれませんそう月初代など聞くには
ロケットです大きなダサいのルックス朝では犠牲のはピカイチ車
さすがカクテキしてドクターと言っているだけあって書きやすさ重視んのん土日は
ピカイチですでも
そしてそのドクターグリップに進化したのはこちらで頂き欺瞞のドクターグリップです
動画このルックさっこいやぁかっこいいね
大変な方は見たことを使ったことがあるのではないでしょうか婆さん日本の誰かで素材
のドッグ指からサイズをかなり習熟されるのか今朝は変わらずグリップの柔らかさも
重視されていてとても書きやすい欠点としてはアレですね
グリップにあぐらがたまりやすいですキャストある独車の方は何の栗栗た学ぶらが好き
なんでわざわざシミ覗くだけにオリーブオイルを注ぎだからもアンビリーバブル父られ
ませバターなるでしょうか誰もが認める柿安でバクはリスト太ければバリエーションを
増やしますオフロード車の対応をイメージしたグリップを採用しているオフローダー時
デリバリーを育てような白いクリップ打つか c スカイタイムと切り
白いクリップ
下ストライプが入っています正直かけにくかったんぱんにも期間切れて無駄に目立つ
防衛のドクターグリップないんじゃ3色リパーゼとおしゃれ解くべく発売しています
必要性には関係ありません
恋し書きやすいんですよ在日だもんなついでに他のシャベも紹介させていただきます
まず有名どころではくるとが三菱ユニーの商品です
これを高めしましたね動かすためにクールだエンドやっぱりてさん寝具のあるという
まさにチャー展開に確認ボタンしますねえぼりゅーしょんですよ
高校でもみんな持ってましたねくるとか[ __ ]です2バージョンだけじゃなくてハイ
グレードタイプっていう
1000円するくるとももある300円とまぁあのプラスティックだけアルミででき
すごい安いです
んですか
たいぐらいとだいぶ発売後しばらくしてから発売されたグリップが握りやすい仕様と
なっていることがローレットタイプ同じって1000円でスローレートタイプつぶつぶ
してて書きやすかったしてをライフ入って買ったんですけどちょっと友達にあげちゃい
ました
だってっ
ドクターグリップが好きなんだも動画で紹介したんですけどプルトがラバークリップ
バーガー待ってますよね国政のところが普通のクルトガはプラスチックなんですけど
ラバーになってちょっと書きやすいでペターもリーズナブルなんで学生の皆さん買い
やすいと思います
うせずにといえばこれが欠かせませんみんな好きだと思いますが難しい使ってたという
方も多いのではないでしょうか
アルファーゲルですこのプリプ握るグリップパターンありませんよね
自分の感じです汗ショップ上部に好きだったのではないでしょうか
好きだったのではないでしょうかまずは太めの初期はアルファゲルこれ思えてクリック
し書く所ありませんし
次にあるファーティ3見た目のプリフィでも最高のただしスリーブタイプ中で細目車便
が苦手な方にをただの棒ですねスティックです
荒川キルシェルっぽく好きでして細ってかっこいい宿陸にするし
が頭良い友達を使ってたんで頭良くなるかなって
ってたんですけど
さらに黄金はつなげるの方面ディフィーノいろいろシャーペン振って芯を出すという
機能が搭載された新シリーズが出たのでスクリプ逃げるにフリフリ日のエロい
実にエロい
これはカラーバリエーションも豊富でどうなるかだから黒キーズのバージョンにクラブ
から市立って言ってあのお寺にかしたいと思ってますよね
けしからグルートだとアルファゲルグリップが合体した衝撃の商品がこのあとってるん
ですね
喋っ強化に衝撃を与えたくるとほどけるクリームがかったに来るとかあるぞ開け
誘拐で起きるとかと呼ばれていますこれでた時ビックリしたけど
そう月くるとはより回転しないしてあるじゃなければねアルファゲルグリップより
ぷにぷにしないからね
甘い者の方がんセンターの止まらないですよではか芸談夢ちゃんビューを少しだけ紹介
していこうと思いますまずパイロットからは夫
釣ってますかオプトこれは野菜315円なのに非常に書きやすいコスは最高で僕三度
嫌いでスマートじゃないです次もパイロットから dx グリップです皆ばなる方多い
のではないでしょうかお菓子からあります安いんじゃなんの文房具屋さんで
100円しなくて置いてあったときもありましたからねこれもなかなか書きやすいです
ください皆に5本まとめ買いしていますと僕は子供の時から花だったようでそして皆
さん秒速5センチメートってアニメ知ってますか有名な新海誠さん書かれたはじめなん
ですけど
短編アニメですねそのアニメの主人公の高木くんの幼馴染なんかねチャンネルがビュー
各的に使ってシャーペンが x grip の黒なんですよ
出ているパイロットからでサイン役を見せてみませんがこれ見た目が派手それだけ
ペン先が引っ込むくらいしか少々ありませんまあまあ書きやすいです以上
次はドイツの文房具メーカーラミーからの醤油
これで見た目がかっこいいですが僕も高校の時誕生日かと思いましたシャンペーンを
なんと服な存在だったのでしょ
boys be ambitious 違いからも有名な文房具が会社ダミーなんです
けど日本では少し特別の中央が病です今朝知ってると思うんですけど有名なんで計&
キャラクターとずらぶたんドンリーチャーがアニメの中で使ってシャーペンがこちら2
ぶりの黄色ペル118なんですよ嫌悪してでしょ
なんかキャップ主人公の名前
なんとか10位
うんたんうんたんだうんたぁうんとアニメけいおんけいおん部の部長の立案が使って
いるサーフィンが堺のこの黄色なんですよ
平和ファンの皆さん開発を早めに就かず残念なんですけどこのピッチャーの使っている
シャーペンのクリップの方
色黒ですよねご覧ください見てわかるんですけどクリップが黒なんですよ23年ほど前
にこのサーフィン全勝のくれ
黒色銀色に変更されてしまってりっちゃんと全くなく喋りは生産終了というわけなの
です
えっちゃんファンの皆さん残念6でまた来週時間ステでもまだまだたくさんあるつを
すごいシャーペン付きなっていると思うて製図用シャーペンですね
パイロットね s シリーズとか
テクト2ウェイとかグラスとかあそぼらへん好きな人もいると思うけど僕ちょっと
せいぜいをサーフィンや学生の皆さんとかなんか書くことが多い方とか
ぜひねー
手元から入ってみてはいかがでしょうかマジでねー
本当に米までいいですよかっこいいよ車便器にしてみてはいかがでしょうかって言う
動画でしたズンッ
ban
dea